hello reject nation I think this is the
last video we're checking out from the
Superbowl today it would seem as though
before we try to just lost in space
ourselves to sleep that so we can catch
solo at the right time tomorrow morning
yeah don't worry Tyrone will get his up
on time because he's three hours ahead
of us yeah lucky geographically favored
all right well this is Wes world seasons
[Music]
Indian
[Music]
you can be free or they shoot this
in the American West or in front of a
screen Oh what is happening whoa
Wow
[Music]
Wow Wow yeah
[Music]
oh that's a perfect trailer it's a
perfect trailer that's a perfect trailer
cuz well I love to check out the
trailers where you can like give really
good probably breakdown yeah yeah story
structures nah man this is like the
perfect eerie tone and style because
when they just transition into that bull
running into that one group of yeah when
it goes from beauty to sinister all in
the pan across the screaming in the
matador now nickname yeah he does seem
to be one of the central players in
bringing whatever West world is right
now to the ground what it looks like
what I can give a prediction about the
plot is it it's because there was a lot
of storylines in season one where
they're very much divided yeah it seems
like this time all the storylines will
come together especially the artificial
intelligence seems like they're all
gonna team up now just take down the
humans because even tani Newton's
storyline ends in a way where she's off
somewhere everyone a lot of people kind
of heading out from there in different
places so this is a war against machines
versus humans the AIS are fighting for
their life at one place in the world
wonder how far how long this show will
go like are they gonna get ridiculous to
the point where they eyes gonna try to
take over outside of West world cuz we
don't even know where West world's
located yet well yeah and I was like are
they gonna also jump into the other
worlds that they've alluded to exactly
show you the Shogun world they have the
Indians in there oh yeah I had two
shogun teases at the end of season 1
you're right yeah there's isn't there
also like future world there I mean this
seems like it's gonna keep its roots in
West world but I am very curious as to
where the show's gonna go cuz the first
season has such a tight arc that ends in
a very specific place and now it seems
like the possibility for storytelling is
so much more broad yeah and I have no
idea where the seasons gonna head and
I'm really excited to see where it yeah
oh man is this a little like I remember
we watched the first season that was the
fastest I think I'd binge anything in a
long time it was addicting there's an
addicting show man I think it's gonna
get a lot more violent and probably to
cut back on the sex because where's the
room for sex here maybe robots gonna
start boning each other more um maybe I
mean they're all developing stuff like
that I mean it seems like they'll
probably be less of it because now they
have a say yeah who do you think's gonna
rise to leadership
it looks like Rachel it looks like Evan
Rachel Wood is rising to leadership here
her aunt Andy Newton man because like I
feel like Maeve has a lot it moves March
I wonder if they're gonna be at odds
with each other I wonder if they're
going to form some kind of uneasy
alliance cuz that's the next thing
moving forward is like where are all the
different AI ya all waking up kind of
simultaneously how are they all gonna
mesh with each other what I'm hoping is
that the AIS don't all just like yeah
let's team up we're good I'm hoping
there's like a little war and conflict
and death within just the AI not
trusting each other because if the theme
of the show is AI is evolving into just
being human that's a thing that would
happen with humans well yeah and they
wouldn't just be like hey we're a I you
know if you think about life life you
respond to things based on things you've
experienced in the past and every one of
the hosts has experienced different
things although I guess you could
surmise that they've all experienced
pretty nasty behaviors yeah I feel like
there's plenty of potential for them to
see eye to eye to not see eye to eye
from conflict and everything in between
and I mean it's just a gorgeous trailer
to look at too I mean they always drink
up the American West if that's where
they shoot well guys I think that's the
end of the Super Bowl trailers for us we
skipped out on red Sparrow well you know
we've seen red Sparrow trailers a few
times now what's 30 more seconds gonna
do I don't know but Avengers was worth
it you guys can subscribe you the real
rejects click that notification bell
let's see if we wake up on time for solo
tomorrow it's really early for us what's
on time really yeah it's true
if you like us enough you'll just
watch it anyway